Let's go next to our caller from the six five
zero area code.
Who's calling today from six five zero
hello.
Is this mean?
That is, yeah.
Who's this?
All right.
So, um, I'm Luke, I'm from the bay area.
Hey, look by bay area standards.
I'm a bit of a moderate, but I'm guess immigrants
from your things.
I'm pretty progressive.
Alright.
And so, um, my questions about like the feasibility
of the progressive plans long term, like I've
seen your videos about like how you know,
it say a Sandra administration would be like
pay for the things like Medicare for all and
the green new deal and stuff like that.
Okay.
But um, I think don't we have to like take
into account like the American politics when
we're thinking about these policies?
So it's like Bernie is, I would say like pretty
far on the left of mainstream American politics.
Um, I worry that um,
hold on Luke, let's explore that.
On what issue is Bernie very far to the left?
To the American population?
No, I did not know population politics.
How politics, who's going?
So you're saying, so I just want on you're
saying compared to are the elected officials
in the House and Senate Bernie to the left?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, I would grant that the, I would say
you're right that the, the public at large
is well to the left of the average of our
house.
Yeah.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Do your thing.
And that's what kind of worrying to me because
like say like, you know, Bernie gets in and
I create some great progressive policies and
you know, um, as ways to pay for it.
But let's say like a few years down the line,
there's a republican that gets collected and
because, um, like it's very hard to scale
back federal spending, uh, from previous administrations.
Um, uh, he or she's not able to do that.
I'm talking to the Republican, right.
And, um, they just, uh, come up with tax cuts
because that's politically popular and that
seems to have always been politically popular.
And, um, so then we continue to, um, this
trend of where some democratic gets in and
you know, kind of creates a change of progressive
policies and increases spending.
And then Republican just come in, don't have
a ways of decreasing spending, but they did,
um, like they cut taxes,
they cut revenue, and then they have programs
on the idea that you, you said this is, this
continues the trend of progressive's getting
in and doing progressive stuff.
And then Republicans come in and then they
cut revenue.
What progressives have done?
What progressive stuff?
Well, like I mean it doesn't even necessarily
have to be a super progressive, which I guess
is one of the things I'm worried about.
Like I know that like Obama, like could, could've
been a lot more progressive, but like he's
still increased spending like you know, with
like the stimulus package and stuff and
okay.
Yeah.
But I mean I think what you have to, so stimulus
package is a onetime expense number one.
So that would be, you're talking about how
once you grow the budget, it's hard to cut
it back down and I agree with you, but then
now you're giving an example of something
that was a onetime stimulus or they did, you
know, it was broken up into a couple of different
things.
I think that what you're maybe not accounting
for here is that there, these are programs
by and large, which are widely supported by
the American public.
So imagine for a second Bernie Sanders becomes
president.
He gets Medicare for all past, it's paid for
through the payroll tax that he has proposed.
But on the backend, employers are no longer
paying health insurance premiums to insurance
companies, copays go away.
All of this different stuff.
Okay.
More or less, we're just replacing spending
with would spending from elsewhere.
If a republican president comes in after four
years of that or eight years of that and says,
Hey, we're cutting taxes and what we're going
to stop paying for is that Medicare for all
the backlash would be insane.
Much the way that it's been insane.
Even trying to repeal Obamacare, which they
haven't been able to do after dozens and dozens
of attempts.
So I think that you're, you're concerned it's
not, it's not a crazy concern.
It's just not in practice the way this would
be played out and it would be a terrible reason
not to do progressive things because a republican
at some point in the future, I might try to
cut the funding for it.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'd agree with that.
Thank you for taking
my call.
I really appreciate you and your show.
Thank you so much.
Really appreciate the phone call.
Great to hear from Luke from the bay area.
Good to hear from you.